welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and after hearing
reports about Marvel's upcoming Disney
plus series Vision Quest I think we're
getting another super group introduced
into the MCU the West Coast Avengers are
the Avengers finally setting up shop in
my home state of California Teslas and
heroes I have a sick air mattress and
y'all can totally come crash at my place
but who will actually show up in the
series if the West Coast Avengers do
show up will we be seeing their 80s
roster or the more modern one or a
hybrid of the two today I'm breaking
down everything you need to know about
the WCA and how Vision Quest can
introduce these Avengers ever since
Hawkeye dropped last year in 2021 we
here new rock stars have been waiting
very patiently for the WCA to finally
show up and but Patiently I mean that
we've all been freaking out about it for
approximately 12 months oh my god dude
I'm freaking out I am so stressed out I
feel like I'm having a panic attack
especially now that we've seen an entire
series take place in Los Angeles with
She-Hulk but before we dive into these
series about who might join the lineup
in Phase 5 or Beyond let's talk about
the wca's comic history back in 1984
Roger Stern and Bob Hall created the
West Coast Avengers number one to follow
the exploits of the superhero team in
California hilariously Hawkeye builds a
compound in California for everyone to
inhabit because even in the 80s rent
prices were too damn High can't have
your Heroes renting separate Apartments
that's more of a friend's New York
scenario even funnier Mockingbird outs
him for attempting to buy Knott's Berry
Farm for their group damn y'all and to
think the Avengers campus could have
been built at knots instead of Disney
for half the ticket price Vision calls
the West Coast Avengers to assemble due
to the fact that there is simply too
many Avengers and Avenger adjacent
Heroes to fit in the New York lineup
after Captain America declared that only
six people can make up the Avengers at
any given time Vision builds a team that
can handle any misdeeds west of the
Rocky Mountains the group initially
includes team leader Hawkeye his wife
Mockingbird James Rhodes under the Iron
Man moniker Tigra Wonder Man and of
course Vish like their New York
counterparts the roster of the WCA has
seen many rotations over their run
including Tony Stark U.S agent Moon
Knight and the original human torch
during Vision Quest namesake art WCA was
made up of Hawkeye the Scarlet Witch
Vision Wonder Man Tigra and the WASP
they also had retired Ant-Man Hank Pym
as their resident scientist that Vision
Quest arcs banned West Coast Avengers
issues 42-45 and culminated in the
reveal of white Vision The Arc begins
with Wanda waking up to find that Vision
has disappeared seemingly out of nowhere
after the compound is attacked by a fake
Ultron robot Mockingbird returns to the
team after her split with Hawkeye to
reveal that she was conned into helping
a spy organization kidnap vision and
infect their database with a virus that
would delete all backups of his data
from their system although the Scarlet
Witch and Mockingbird race to save him
the two find him in pieces similar to
what we saw in Wanda Vision it turns out
that a global operation run by the CIA
mi7 the KGB and other intelligence
agencies was tasked with eliminating
Vision after he tapped into high
security computer systems across the
world in Avengers number 253. this group
known as vigilance posed his shield so
they could completely wipe vision's data
from every database on the planet AKA a
they've erased all of his memories and
even though Hank Pym puts him back
together physically as the white Vision
his soul is lost in the process although
we've already seen vision's body taken
apart and Wanda's hex Vision restore
parts of white vision's memory in the
MCU I do think that the comics Vision
Quest storyline will lead into what the
MCU does next with fission after all we
still have white Vision pondering the
ship of Theseus wherever he is and he
does have all of regular vision's
memories inside of him obviously with
Paul Bettany returning as a lead plenty
of vision quests will be a journey of
self-discovery but the comic's Vision
Quest was named more so after the West
Coast Avengers searching for vision so
like the upcoming MCU series title
suggests I believe that we might see the
seeds of the WCA assembled in the beat
plot quest to find the missing Vision
but with such a large lineup of
potential West Coast Avenger members
which ones would make the most sense for
tracking down Vision in this phase of
the MCU I stare at screens all day and
that can be tough on my eyes it used to
be the case that I'd help my eyes out by
wearing a pair of blue blocks blue light
glasses but blue box has become bonchar
thankfully the glasses have stayed the
same got my little glasses in a little
case and now I'm gonna put them on my
little face
wowie phone charge is a couple of
different glasses depending on what you
need my go-to are the computer glasses
they help reduce Sore Eyes headaches
watery eyes and fatigue if I'm staring
at a computer all day or I'm in a room
with fluorescent lights these glasses
are my first line of defense boncharge's
glasses are backed by science and tested
to make sure they work which is not the
case with other light blocking glasses
on the market if you've got a
prescription you can get these with a
prescription if you don't you can get
them without a prescription just need a
pair of light blocking reading glasses
Bond charge can handle that too Bond
charge ships worldwide and have other
great products like low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and 100 light
blocking sleep masks go to boncharge.com
new rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 that's
b-o-n-c-h-a-r-g-e.com Slash new
rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 well let's start
with the Hawkeyes both and Kate have
been Premier leaders of the WCA with
Barton leading the team in the 80s and
Bishop in the 2018 Revival Barton would
be the perfect Shield agent for the job
in a race to hunt down Vision if Global
agencies follow in hayward's footsteps
and try to recover Visions Tech and
weaponry for their own schemes Bishop
has a habit of tagging along against
Barton's wishes but I could also see her
learning International Espionage on the
job with her Mentor since we have both
Hawkeyes active and much of the MCU is
bending 80s plots with the odds and
Beyond I actually think that we'll end
up with a cool hybrid WCA team tiger is
next on my short list because back in
Hawkeye episode 1 there was a character
who shared her alter ego's unique first
name Kate's classmate and accomplice in
her school bell tragedy was named Greer
in the comics Greer Grant Nelson is
Tiger's civilian name tiger is one of
the wca's core members and even though
she was part of the original team I
could see the MCU aging her down then we
have the puzzle of Mockingbird while we
did see Bobby morse's Mockingbird back
in Agents of Shield the mcu's timeline
and incorporation of this TV series
Canon isn't super consistent however in
the Hawkeye series it was hinted that
Clint's wife Laura also used the code
name Mockingbird during her stinted
Shield many fans speculated that she may
rejoin the world of herodom in upcoming
on-screen Adventures of the two I
actually want Bobby morse's Mockingbird
more despite Laura's ties to Hawkeye but
he's been slowly rolling out the
recanonization of other Marvel
properties and Adrian palicki's
Mockingbird kicked major ass but like he
is probably pretty busy on Disney's
other series The Orville so I don't have
my hopes up too high we also know that
another founding WCA member Wonder Man
will be getting his own series on Disney
plus Disney Plus
foreign
II cast in the titular role Wonder Man
is known for being a big Hollywood stunt
man so he'll likely be in the right area
to join the team he's also intrinsically
tied division in the comics Simon
Williams agrees to be the test subject
of zemo's ionic Ray treatment which
promises to give him super powers like
super strength speed stamina
vulnerability senses regenerative
healing and even immortality he can also
teleport shapeshift and manipulate
energy with his new powers however these
Powers came with a price in order to
keep him as a member of the Masters of
evil Zemo also created a weakness in his
metabolic system that would kill him in
a week without the secret antidote he
refused to betray The Avengers however
without the antidote fell into a coma
his brain patterns were recorded and
later used to build Vision with this
comic-based link division my theory is
that we'll see him in Vision Quest as
well as in his own series although the
MCU May simplify his role he played a
major part of vision's history in the
comics perhaps he's still somehow a
blueprint for vision's Consciousness and
therefore would be a great Ally to help
white Vision make sense of himself maybe
they even just become Bros and vision
relearns what it means to be human
through the guidance of his actor pal
speaking of Heroes in the LA area we've
also got She-Hulk lawyering out there
while She-Hulk has never been an
official West Coast Avenger she has
teamed up with them multiple times and
all good Avengers teams need a Hulk what
are a few of these heroes are likely to
be cameos or Side characters in Vision
quests that can set up a future WCA but
what about WCA members for the MCU
outside of Vision Quest I could also
potentially see Kamala Khan joining the
West Coast Avengers roster down the line
as she's part of the Kate Bishop team as
for the other newbie West Coast Avengers
from Kate Bishop's comic crew we've got
America Chavez who he met in Multiverse
of Madness and gwenpool although America
Chavez is currently a student of the
Mystic Arts at cumbertage we've seen
Wong take a vacation or two outside
their compound who's to say that the
girl who used to jump from Multiverse to
Multiverse using her star portals won't
be able to sneak out of there the next
time Juan goes to Los Angeles after
freeing Abomination if you love Mt as
much as I do you probably already
watched his theory video on why he
thinks when and pause coming to the MCU
and I gotta say I agree with him her
backstory goes like this a little baby
comic book nerd achieves all of her
wildest fantasies when she finds herself
as an actual hero in Marvel Comics if
her storyline were to carry over to the
MCU her arrival could like a lot of
other catastrophic events be a result of
the fractured Multiverse and the
Divergent timelines established in phase
four and now the Deadpool himself is
officially a Disney princess AKA part of
the MCU instead of just the fox first
it's not far-fetched to think that
gwenpool could show up too I love the
idea that she could crawl out of the
thumbnail after She-Hulk in order to
enter the MCU regardless of who exactly
ends up appearing on the West Coast
Avengers lineup I know one thing to be
true I am taking all of them to the
In-N-Out burger right by LAX as soon as
they get off the plane but I want to
know who you guys think could show up in
the WCA in the comments follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at whitneypuppy
follow me Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
thank you